so when I was taught as a student I was
taught by a chemist at Cambridge called
alpha magic who during the Second World
War was working in Canada on the
plutonium chemistry and one night he
managed the spill the entire UK's supply
of plutonium which was only ten
milligrams on to the bench in the lab
and so rather than saying oh dear I have
spilt it he went and got a saw and
soared a large chunk out of the bench
and burnt the wood and got back nine and
a half of the ten milligrams that he
spilt and nobody would have known except
at that point he was too tired to repair
the bench so they came back in the
morning and there was a large hole in
the bench to show what he had done okay
so plutonium
I think plutonium is quite well known
for the fact it's been used in certain
types of nuclear bombs it's a very
interesting element it's incredibly
dense
if you hold a golf ball size shape of
plutonium in your hand it would weigh in
excess of half a kilogram which is one
heavy golf ball and if you were holding
it you would have to be holding it
through several layers of gloves at
least one of which would be lead-lined
and as you held it it would be like
having a really hot cup of tea in your
hand and that's from the major activity
coming out it's just the sheer heat of
the reactivity which you would be
feeling I also had an interesting
experience with at a conference a I was
sitting next to a lady who I asked her
why she was at the conference which was
about a supercritical fluids using
high-pressure gases as solvents and I
asked it asked her why she was there and
she said she worked with weapons-grade
plutonium what is used in making Aten
bombs and she said she was worried about
the environmental effects of using
chlorinated solvents these are compounds
of carbon and chlorine for removing the
grease from the plutonium they were
using to make the bombs so she wizard
the conference
see whether you could use high-pressure
carbon dioxide or
as an alternative to make the making of
atomic bombs more environmentally
friendly which I thought was a slightly
McCobb worry about the environment I do
like that I want to make more
environmentally friendly Edinburgh yes
I've not seen any because the sort of
facilities you need to be able to handle
it are way beyond what you find in a
normal University I've heard so many
fascinating stories about it those such
as it's incredibly dense and a few
people at the atomic weapons agency
wanted to cut a little piece off and it
took three of them were the hacks or
several hours and several hacksaw blades
before they finally got a tiny little
chip off so it's incredibly dense and
hard hence the the high weight for its
size
plutonium is is quite a poisonous
element and there have been a number of
cases particularly the famous case in
America with Karen Silkwood who was
poisoned
or had traces of poisonous plutonium
found in her refrigerator and all
through her flat which in fact inspired
my brother to write a play called
stronger than the Sun in the early 1970s
one of his first successful television
films and perhaps a little-known thing
about plutonium because obviously it has
a pretty bad image in terms of its use
in nuclear weapons is that it's what
helped power the astronauts on the moon
landings in the 60s and 70s